[Applaudissements]
d'avoir ce type de pantalon
tu pars avec le [ __ ] d'être assez
chaud là je pars en afrique du sud pour
donner ne crois pas joué mon faux
la lanière belles chaussures que nous
donne le ton
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je le fais mais je me demande si c'est
pas mieux sans moi c'est comptant lever
les chaussures ya une petite odeur de y
est presque
[Applaudissements]
imagine si besoin de laurent delahousse
et tessa bonsoir à tous merci
alors les titres du journal mais si je
me sens hyper bien sûr que c'est comme
si les voilà je me sens dans une salle
passer de l'autre côté ou non question
je vais compter jusqu'à 2020 si ça
arrive c'est incroyable ce qui s'est
déjà aligné à la place de mala bouder
c'est sûr